Hello, everybody, my name is Markiplier, and welcome back to
West of Loathing.
I've recuperated from the horrors that I experienced in the ghost town.
Of-Of eternal of perpetual paper work
but here we're gonna carry on and get to the bottom of the of the mail situation so we can build this bridge.
"What is- What a place is"
"It's a postal way station... do you know about mail? How do goblins communicate over long distances?"
"Popping! Spores floating on winds, new goblins growing, saying a message!"
That's fucking *laughs* Groooossss
AAh
Disgusting.
'Postal Service Property NO TRESSPASSING`
I'mma  trespass. (Thug Life)
Ooo hello~
Go through em'! 'A letter to Roy Bean'
Alright.
Go through em'! 'Blank post cards' Go through em'!
'Reboot Hill, An article in here about how they had to change the name of a nearby cemetery due to so many skeletons being raised there'
'You marked down the cemetery's location'
Alright
Newspapers 'Someone removed all the funnies so there's literally no reason to care about them'
You're god damn right you are~
"This cabinet is full of maps, but you have no idea what any of them mean."
"Maybe you could ask about it at the los- post office in Dirtwater."
"Yeah, maybe." "Or maybe not."
Alright. I'll go with "Yeah, maybe."
Alright. What's over here?
Why is an outhouse in here?
"You don't even *hold back laughter* what(want) tpu(to) know
what bureaucratic processes were involved in the placement of *giggles* this outhouse."
Why is there an outhouse on the in-house?
Why is there in-outhouse?
Why is there out-in-house house house house..
I have no money.
Let's go to Reboot Hill and farm me up some money.
Please.
Oh.
"You sense an extremely powerful, extremely malicious cow presence nearby."
Oooooh~
Hellstrom Ranch?
Hell yeah! I'm going to Hellstrom Ranch!
How powerful are we talking here?!
WooOAH HO HO Ho hoho ho oh!
That is a rip in a dimension!
"Oh! Wow! Yikes!"
"What's up. Gary?"
"Weird feelings! A sensation of puzzling!"
"Huh?"
"From that direction coming!"
West Pole.
*Giggles* The West Pole?
Really?
The West Pole?!
"Ringing this will attract the attention of at least one infernal cow."
"It's a portal to Hell! You hear the ominous mooing."
"This sure seems like a powerful source of Hellcow energy.."
Ookay.
Alright. "The only part of this shed that didn't burn was this horseshoe attached. Guess it's really good luck."
I got a Lucky Horseshoe.
Good for me.
Pistol Attack Damage.
GOD Dammit! Why wasn't I a Snake Oiler?!
Ahh! I wish I was Snake Oil.
That'd be so much better than this.
I wanna shoot things and people.
Alright. Let's fight at least one cow.
Hello.
Gary! Don't let him do that to ya.
Okay, Gary! Let him do that to ya so I don't deal with it.
What is that?
Wait...
Wait.
"Gary will blast all of your enemies with spores, reducing all their stats."
That sounds horrifying.
Okay, Gary. There was no point to that.
Alright, Gary. Hit em' with your best shot.
Gary, that's a terrible shot.
Gary, you're disappointing me.
You're nothing but a disappointment, and..
Frankly, I don't love you anymore.
Ow.
Baam!
Alright. Well, I got that.
"They're super evil."
Alright. Roasted Cow Tongue.
But at least now I can get a better lock picking.
I could've get better Dickerin' eventually, but...
Not now. *Sigh*
Sadly, not now.
Alright, what's in here?
Woah.
Hello.
"You lack the proper leatherworking expertise to use these tools."
AAWWW!
"Bookshelf mostly burned."
"Burned Leatherworking Manual."
Am I about to get-
Am I get to- bout to get.
I just got Leatherworking.
Oh! "After you're done reading it, you understand that the book itself is bound in valuable leather!"
"You tear it *giggles* apart so you can make something else from it."
Alright!
Alright.
Make something out of think leather.
Oooh~
*Gasp*
I can make my own hat?!
I can make my OWN HAT?!
OOOOOH!
I could get a meat bonus though.
I like!
A new hat plea- AW! LOOK AT THAT HAT!
I'mma make something! I'mma make a BAG!
Oh hell yeah!
Oh, I'mma make me some PANTS!
Oh! Look at those pants!
Oh!
OH!
AH!
YEAH!
I'mma get Lassos!
OH!
UGHH!
Hell yeah.
Gimme those pants!
Oh, sorry Kneeling Pants.
You gotta make way for the better pants here.
Oh. Look at that hat.
AWW!
Ugh! Not as good.
I don't like it as good.
But it's got so much muscle, I got to wear it.
It's a good hat.
Mm.
It's gonna grow on me.
Alright, maybe it's a shitty hat.
It's pretty bad hat.
It's-it's a disgustingly bad hat.
I actually don't like this hat at all.
I don't like that.
But I'mma go to West Pole for some reason.
"Fort Memoriam"
Alright. I'll go there real quick. And THEN I'll go to the West Pole.
Alrig- I'll be- I'm-I'm not gonna stop in here.
I gotta- I'm gonna continue on.
I keep getting distracted by different things that I'm not supposed to be going.
Oh!
Hi, wanderin' Sally.
How you doing?
I ah.
I don't really have anything that I..
I don't know why I stopped here actually.
I'm gonna leave now.
Okay, I'm gonna leave.
I'mma put on my black cap because I like that hat better. That hat
looked way better than this.
And I'm more about aesthetic than
I am about functional purpose!
I shout into Sally's face.
Oh.
Bones?
Woah!
The Cairncow?!
What The Fuck is that?
Imma Get Beefy for that one
Shit Dude!
Bam!
PEEA PEEAA PEAAAAAAAAAAA
Go Garry Go..
Oh
That ain't good...
BAAMM
Hitcha With a BONE You stack of Bones!
Take some of THAT with ya
What the Fuuuccckk??
This Yucca wants to be further east
than it is.
Alright
Loco weed. That's what Timflr would like but I can't do that.
Pile of weird rocks. Mess with them.
Alright.
"They don't seem to weigh much-as much as they should
and they're sort of drawn to each other.
You could probably make an interesting cairn out of them."
Something... Suave~
Oh.
A.. cool zigzag.
Ooh!
That's cool!
Uh-huh
That's nice! Something powerful! An impregnable-
Woah
I got a perk
Heart of Stone?
"Your circulatory system is partly stone now
which makes your blood even more thicker than water than *laughs* regular blood."
I thought that was a penis.
I thought that was straight up a penis.
Something mystical.
A mystical sigil.
Ah!
Nice!
Make a... nother tower..
Mmm!
That's good! Something suave!
Cool zigza - Nah! I'mma make - I'mma make something nice!
Gonna make some - Sassy face!
Ahh that's not sassy
that's a weird face.
That is a goddamn weird face.
That's a goddamn weird face.
"Nothing special about it apart from the fact that it isn't in a pile."
Alright. Pick it up!
"Oof it's way heavier than it looks. You can't budge it at all."
Weird.
Alrighty then.
What about...
What if I make all of these super manly tower penises?
What if I do that?
Huh?
No not that.
There we go.
Alright, got that!
How 'bout that now?
"Why is this happening?"
Alright fine then!
I'm gonna make you into somethin' I don't wanna make.
Threatening fist!
Uggh!
*giggling* Just take some of that!
AAAAAHH!
Alright, fine there was no point in being here.
I'm gonna go to Reboot Hill 'cause why not.
Oh.
"There isn't a whole lot to occupy yourself during these long rides -
if you've seen one cloud that looks like a duck, you've seen them all.
It'd be a good opportunity to exercise your upper-body, but you don't have any dumbbells."
"Try to straighten a spare horseshoe.."
Okay
Alright
I'll do that.
"You spend some time grunting and puffing, trying to unbend a horseshoe
with your bare hands. It doesn't work. But it's quite a workout."
Good for me!
I'm a musclehead! I'm a Cow Puncher! That's what I do and that's how I do it.
"Wow, these trees! Hello! Such trees they are for spooking!"
"Yeah, no kidding. These are Grade-A Scary Trees."
"I hope they not my soul to sucking out!"
"I don't really know anything about goblin religious beliefs.
Do you guys believe in souls?"
"Yes! But we... sharing? It's complicated!"
Alright, Gary! You carry on.
*ghost voice* Reboot Hiiiiillll
"Don't worry it's just paint."
*ghost voice* Not blooood
*ghostly moaning*
Jeez.
There's a keyhole in the trunk of this tree?
What?!
Well I don't have a key do I??
I don't know if I have a key. I have no idea if I have a key.
Do I have a key?
Well it's not prompting me so I'm assuming it's not there.
Don't know why I'm goin' over here.
Well there's a whole lot of nothin' over here but I'll look out for a key that goes to that tree.
Eventually.
Hello? Plot one..
"You see the ghost of an elderly woman holding flowers.
She seems lost and depressed, above and beyond what's expected for a ghost."
"Howdy ma'am is there something I can help you with?"
"Oh, it's awful! I can't remember! I can't remember at all!"
"Let's start at the beginning, okay?"
"Well, you see, I had four daughters. They married four brothers, the Smith boys,
and after that they each had five daughters or their own.
Unfortunately, I outlived every single one of the twenty-four of them."
"Uh.. you, ah... You know you're a ghost, right?"
"Oh yes. In fact, I died here in this graveyard, where they're all buried.
I came to visit them, and I suppose my poor old heart finally gave out.
That's not the problem, though - 95 years is a pretty good run after all."
"So what did you forget?"
"I brought this bouquet of flowers to put on my favorite granddaughter's grave.
But I can't remember which of them was my favorite!
I'm so ashamed, and I can't bear to leave until I've remembered!"
"Oh I see. Well maybe I can help you figure it out."
"Oh, thank you. I'd appreciate that ever so much!"
Alright
What do you remember?
"First name ended in a vowel."
"Okay. Anything else?"
"When I was 40 she was born. Oh, no, 37. Or was it 42?
It must have been somewhere in that range at least."
Okay, alright
Anything else?
"Her first name was longer than her last, just like mine."
*yawning* Okayy... Anything else?
"She wasn't buried next to any of my other daughters."
Anything else?
'She sniffs a little'
"She passed at the poor and same age as poor, poor Becky who was always in such ill health."
Anything else?
"Favorite hobby was knitting. She knit me a lovely sweater for Crimbo just the year before she died.
That's all I can remember."
"Knitting. Okay then. Hang on, let me think a moment."
"I think I know who she was."
Nah I don't I have no goddamn idea. How would I know
Oh jeez
Hang on!
I'll.. be with you
God dammit!
Uggh
Uh.. Rebecca Smith..
Could be her.
Nooooo
Wait
Rebecca Smith, THAT's her.
Okay
So in 18-FORTY
..ish
she was born.
Not you.
Wise Old..
"This time the bar ate him"
Alright, let's dig it up.
I got a marmotskin hat?!
OOH!
GOD DAMMIT
IF ONLY I WAS A SNAKE OIL SALESMAN
GOD THIS HAT'S COOL!!
Peggy Immortal.. Kinda ironic.
Big Bob Hurlingham! Gone to the big pie-eating *chuckles* contest in the sky.
I got a... tripe pie..?
Gross!
Aww I can't I'm too full. ( ͡° ͜ʖ ͡°)
Biff Bunkerston *chuckle* he was a real buttface...
Was he now?
Snidely Crandlesworth, he as sort of like a Benjamin Button kind of thing.
1800 to 1700?!
Clean Willie Hinks, really gonna- really is gonna hate this burial thing.
Annette Centibaum, tried to eat her way out of a bear.
Alright.
Buck Jeansly
Nobody saw a man die that way before.
A whole gang buried in here!
Alright!
I'll bash you-( ͡° ͜ʖ ͡°) woahoh!
Woah!
WOAH
WoAH
WOaH
WOAh
WAOH
WOOOAH
WOOAH
Wo*voice crack*oah
woah
I don't like this...
I'm gonna bull rush ya~!
I'm gonna GORE you!
MERRRRRRRRRRRF
Oh that didn't work at all!
OH
I'm gonna die *famous last words*
I'm- I'm dead I'm dead
Oh-waaah
Well..
I got Angry.
But I passed ou-HA
I got so angry that I passed out!
HAHAH
HAAAAA
HAHAHAH
Aww it's only day two
Wow holy sh!t I made it pretty far!
Welp
Time to get myself pissed of ag-
HAHAHAH-ain!
ugh
UGH ( ͡° ͜ʖ ͡°)
My red bellied-
GRAAAAH
RRRRRR
I'm so grumpy!
So grumpled (?)
Heh heh
Awwwww geez
Anything interesting?
Awwwww- miniature piano?
What the hell what does that do?
Piano isn't playing- turn it on. ( ͡° ͜ʖ ͡°)
(help me with the lenny faces pls kill me)
So merry, so tinkly (tinkling)
Okay! Alright then.
Anything else in this spittoon? (ew)
Anything else in this nice spittoon?
Off to one side of the trail, you spot a cactus that doesn't look quite right.
Specifically it doesn't look right because it has a goblin face.
As you get closer, you become pretty sure that it is actually is just a golbin in a cactus outfit.
It gives you some annoying side-eyes and tries to wave you away, but the cactus-arms aren't very mobile.
Do you know a guy called Cactus Bill?
Shh! Going away!
Gary! Talk to this guy.
Turning out goblin is cactus shepherd!
Shepherd?
Cactus herd from predators defending!
Do cac-ti have predators?
Other golbins, mostly.
Okay alright that makes sense, okay, alright, sure... Alright.
Roy Bean's house of justice and jelly beans.
Don't know why I'm here.
Morning ambulations...
Mo- morning ablutions!
Flushed!
Hurraaaay!!! I flushed another god damn thing.
GAAAAAAASP
A SPITO*voice crack*AAAOOONN!!!
Yes... ( ͡° ͜ʖ ͡°)
It's a spittoon nothing special about it.
Spittoon: :(
Investigate...
As soon as you get near the spittoon, you can smell the overpoweringly-sweet stetch it exudes. (ew)
Nauseatingly sweet, like the rotting corpse of a dead gummi bear.
Look inside.
Garish ranbow colors swirl together in congealing psychadelic madness.
Is Roy using jellybeans as chewing tobacco?
Yes. Yes, of course he is. (Of course he is)
Investigate further!
We're talking about a bowl of jellybeans that have been sucked on, half-chewed, and then spat into a brass bucket.
Do you seriously want to put your hand in that swill of artificial coloring and thickened saliva? (Damn right)
It will probably never be clean again.
Go for it... ( ͡° ͜ʖ ͡°) (WAIT WHAT!?)
Look... I'm serious.
You're about to permanently dye your hand with a swiling mishmash of all the worst colorsin the spectrum.
No one will ever have a tattoo that looks as gross or as stupid.
GIVE IT TO MEEEI!!! ( ͡° ͜ʖ ͡°)
Well it tried...
Don't ever say I didn't warn you!
You plunge your hand into the spittoon and fish around for a while. (EW)
Eventually you pull out a really disgusting pistol-
-and a really disgusting hand to shoot it with. ಠ_ಠ
I got Spittoon Hand...
Your hand has been purmuly (permanently) stained by the rainbow-colored contents of a nasty spittoon.
On the bright side, that hand will never suffer anything worse than that ever again. (Really? ( ͡° ͜ʖ ͡°))
Awww that's awesome!
It'll probably make a 'ptoo' sound when you shoot it.
I love tha-hahahah-t...
(1 sub = 1 prayer)
YEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEY!!!
YEEEEEY
Yipiee
YIPIE
YUU
YUUUUU
YOUUUUU~ (souja boi)
Yipie yupuyuw~
woah
There's a single single yellow-jellybean in this case, with a sign that says:
PARAGUAYAN MURDERBEE HONEY JELLY BEAN
VERY RARE
What kind of lunatic would pay 6,000 meat for a single jellybean?
Not this guy and that's for sure.
I said NO.
Aww geez that's a good pistol.
Oh
Wop
There we go.
Ahh that's a good pistol.
BETTER than my toilet pistol, I'll give you that.
God, I wish I was a snake salesman!
(go) BWAAAAAH
I wish I was a snake oiler! ಠ_ಠ
SNAKE OILER! That would be sooo COOOOL!
'Howdy there, pilgrim. Name's Roy Bean.'
'Howdy, Roy. I'm Mumflr Fumperdink.'
'What do you have here?'
'Well. When I first came to these part, I was all about two things:'
'dispensin' justice and dispensin' jellybeans.'
'I was the biggest name in bounty-huntin' and candy-sellin' anyone ever heard of.'
'Gosh! What happened!"
'Oh nothin' particularly tragic.'
'got old, is all. Hung up is my pistol for good.' He points at the wall.
He's pointing at an empty hook on the wall, over a spittoon.
'I still sell some jellybeans from time to time, but they're out of fashion'
'This ol' place is just a jellybean museum, now.'
Alright.
'I found this letter addressed to you.
'A letter?'
Give it to him.
He opens it.
Snorts derisively, and tosses it into the fireplace behind him.
'Thanks anyway.'
'For a jellybean museum, I sure don't see very many jellybeans.'
'Huh'
'A buncha crooks an' shady characters stole 'em!'
'All three jars!'
'S'pouse they think I'm a soft target now that I'm retired.'
'I'll help you give them back!'
'Well now,I certainly 'preciate the assistance.'
Can't offer much in the way of reward,
but I can tell ya which way the group of thieves went
if ya happen' out that direction
okay I'll go get'em!
ahhh not for sale!?
The lack of jelly beans is not for sale
*chuckle*
Funny. Funny funny funny.
Hello, Gary!
"Oh! Oh a place for going,
Gary is thinking of one!"
"Really? What's that?"
"A cactus! A biggest cactus ever seeing! With goblins inside!"
You discovered a map location: Ol' Granddad
WELL that does sound interestin', and/or weird...
Alright, well yeah okay alright
got that thank you
thank you very much
alright
WELL
might as well go to the jelly bean theme side out
oh no
Madness Maw Mine
alright I'll go there
but I'm not gonna stay there
I like the idea of  Madness Maw Mine
bu- woooh ok
Im not gonna fawkin outa here
Holy shit
Im fokin outa here *giggles*
Awahh
Alright Ima attack you
ooo!
Hey! Ima shoot you with my stupid pistol
Bwang!
Uhh its good damage x2
*lazy ass attack from that guy*
Heya indeed
Bang! *victory yay yay*
Bam bitch Holy shit
Alright
HEY! HEY YOU JELLA BEAN BASTARDS AGHH *you tell em marky!*
You approach the bandits seated around the fire. The meanest-lookin' one speaks up
Dunno who ya think ya are, stranger but ya better turn yerself right around and head back the way ya came, less'n ya wanna eat lead.
Well thats not very neighborly!
You fellas stole a jar of jellybeans from an old man, and I aim to have them back.
Oh, is that right? An' just how are ya plannin' on doin' that?
*reads options* WITH CRAZINESS? AAA I WISH I HAD INTIMIDATIN 5 *laughs uncontrollably*
Wait can I he he he
I wanna get a intimidating 5
Thats amazing
AAAAAAAAAA A THOUSAND?
A THOUSAND XP?
Right Ima be back go on a farming adventure the likes you've never seen before
A shirtless man in tight stretchy pants charges at you of of nowhere
No more! No more mushrooms! No more yogurt! No more exploring my inner consciousness while running in place! Im gonna kill something! Kill it and eat it!
Holy jeez
You put on your angriest face and puff up your muscles to look real imposing
Hold it right there, you...
It isn't working, he's still charging at you.
Take the hit!
The guy stomps at you pretty badly. Fortunately, he's too crazed to actually stop and eat you like he said, and runs off into the forest
You gain an effect: ANGRY!
*screams
God damnit!
Ah fuckaduckleme
FUCKADUCKLEME
Alright fuck it Im fine just going to the Thieves
I dont have intimidating 5
It wouldnt take too long
Im too lazy
GODDAMNIT ILL FIX IT LATER
AAAAAAAAAAAA
Im crazy!
BLAH BLAH BLAH *mark talks nonshit* Calm down mark
The bandits hang their heads and shamefully and shuffle away
Thats right you asshooooles
Better walk away- oo!
A filthy bedroll alright
Missing beans- Grab em!
Food supply! Sasspaprarillia- oh
I need to turn off that little tiny miniature piano *BUT WHYYYY*
Wait- Would you like to turn it off? Sure! There we go!
Thats better Jesus
Ill-gotten goods, ohh nice!
Pretty nice bedroll, must've stolen it.
Open it. Alright! D- ooh, dynamite. I like that.
Oh, got some goods, needle, cheap whiskey, meat?
Alright, I'll take it! I seem to be short on meat these days.
Yipes!
Hey buddy! I got your beans back!